the year-long extravaganza got off to a
bright start on Saturday with an opening
ceremony accompanied by light
installations the picturesque southern
Belgian town had been working hard for
years to try to win the coveted title
and now finally it's living the dream
more than 100,000 locals and visitors
attended the inaugural festivities
capital of the culture area 2015 it's
very rewarding for us it's just so happy
to have such a great city promoting the
culture to everyone all ages so everyone
looks at most here now so it's very very
great for us mom's flourished in
medieval times as a production center of
luxury textiles the legacy of that
wealthy era is visible today in
buildings such as Sant waddle church and
the many stately townhouses plus the
primary landmark of malls the belfry a
unesco world heritage site in the 19th
century mounts also became a center for
coal mining but with deposits running
out the city has certainly seen better
days in financial terms unemployment
stands at twenty percent although that's
improved since 2007 that was when Google
chose moans for its European data center
the city was a bit sleeping for years
because after the end of the golden 60s
the end of the coal mine exploitation
most was in very bad economic and social
situation I know we have more or less
undred big and small enterprises waiting
or to zoom out together around 2,000
employments mons is in Belgium's
industrial valley now it wants to become
a European Silicon Valley so the most
street review is one of its many
innovative projects artist collective X
TNT and local residents joined forces
last summer to create this offbeat
alternative to Google's more famous
Street View application
but moms also has classic art to go with
the contemporary among the highlights of
the year is the Museum of Fine Arts and
its major exhibit on Vincent van Gogh it
was while living in this region that he
decided to become a painter rather than
a preacher the museum is displaying
around 70 of the Masters early paintings
and sketches using local motifs the show
runs through May seventeenth for local
organizers the show is part of a very
specific philosophy to change the
mentality to make people believe that
it's possible to to go further to to
change something in your way of living
today that's the big change the big
challenge of the this project this
exhibition but also for european capital
of culture when it comes to going
further there's no meaning love cause
it's a poetry installation across the
entire town tracking its cultural
heritage with material added every year
we're here every day talking with the
people they see us and so it's really an
history that we write with the people of
moose but it's not just the cultural
scene that should benefit the cityscape
will be spruced up to two new concert
halls are being built one being the
arsenic then they'll also be a new train
station designed by renowned architect
santiago calatrava it's due to open in
2018 and right next to that the new mix
Congress Center it was designed by
American architect Daniel liebe skinned
to host international conferences
some 350 million euros are being poured
into the local infrastructure and a
further 70 million are being spent on
cultural programs private sponsors and
the Belgian government came up with most
of the cash they want to use the capital
of culture celebrations to put the
region on the map I have to be honest
nobody in Europe those moss and it's
normal except some people but no they
are going to to see the news images and
they are going to hear about the van
Gogh exhibition and I don't know if they
come not for most but for van gock but
all challenges when they come here's see
I'm going to discover a beautiful city
organizers expect the events to attract
some two million visitors to mons and
hopefully future investors too if that
happens then things will indeed be
looking up for this european capital of
culture